welcome back to CBS this morning it's
that time to bring you some of the
stories that we call talk at the table
but before we do that this is a very
extra extra special day for us because
we're celebrating our eighth birthday
I remember eight years ago eight years
ago where you tried it's like you're
going to school for the first day and
you've got to pick out a very special
dress yellow is my favorite color so
it's the only day that I wear this dress
on our anniversary so I've worn it every
every ever since 2012 look at you and
you are changed at all I just said your
name is due to where my hair looks the
same we need to do something I need
another hair doe so well that's it never
mind I know you still like the show do
you like the dress or do you wear it it
only I only wear it here I only wear it
here and I only wear it on this day
especially for the first day whether you
did I did Alex the designer was Alex
Kramer I don't even know Alex Kramer but
I got a bunch of dresses because I knew
I wanted to wear yellow yeah and here it
is it's the only time I wear it cool and
I can still fit into it on promising on
CW Weight Watchers thank you for that
you